good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about why and how you can
read more reading the reason that
reading is so important there are the
millions and billions and billions and
gazillions of people that have lived
before all of us there's no new problem
you could have with your parents with
school with a bully with anything
there's no problem you can have that
someone has an errand solved and wrote
about it in a book so the keys to life
are running and reading I'm more Wyatt
I've been quiet but like she just you
know she encouraged me like I'm getting
older now so she encouraged me to you
know just speak up it's like you have
something to stay and you know in my dad
he um he were reading this book called
um Rich Dad Poor Dad right and I'm just
you know just that whole book I think
like of him just he'd that's easy
it's like he's guiding me like
throughout the whole book is why did you
want to share that book with your son um
yes it's interesting that when no matter
how successful you get is really
difficult to shake your mindset and I I
still have a poor person mentality I
can't shake it and it gets really
detrimental when you can't just shake
off the ideas it's like when I go to
sleep at night right now who I'm as
financially nervous as I was 20 years
ago
you are absolutely really you should get
well you bet your daughter little more
than us no but I I don't worry I'm not
nervous about it I'm not nervous about
it but I do understand that whole thing
about spending yeah because once you
have a lot of money I mean who knows
what a million dollars can really do you
know I know what $29.99 what what what
do you do yeah yeah it's like with my
kids I just don't I want I want them to
be able to have a
a financial comprehension to not be
slaves to working and money the the way
that my mind has I'm breaking it now but
the weight of my mind has focused and
that's fantastic I write books because
the greatest influence on my life were
the books that I read books have formed
me who I am today how I think what I
feel have all been formed by what I read
everything that you want to do in your
life will be made easier and better and
more fulfilling by reading I know that
sounds kind of crazy and well I don't
know how reading is going to relate to
this or beings gonna relate to that but
everything because at its core it's a
way into imagining what it's like to be
someone else imagining what it would be
like to have a life different from your
own it allows you to imagine
possibilities for yourself and for the
people around you that you otherwise can
never imagine so it just expands the map
of your world and and that in turn
allows you to live a life different from
the one that maybe you think you're
faded to it's really a pleasure for me
to be able to talk to you about Ben
Graham but I've had some lucky days in
my life but one of the luckiest was in
1949 when I was 19 years old and Lincoln
Nebraska and I picked up a copy of the
intelligent industrially changed my
investment philosophy it really changed
my whole life I'd be a different person
at a different place if if I hadn't have
first seen that book I got a bedrock of
investment philosophy that really hasn't
changed ever since I read the book I may
embellish on it a little here and there
but it was Ben's ideas that sent me down
the right right path I'll tell you
honestly the book the book I'm reading
which I was sort of thinking should I
say this or not but it's it's a book on
how Hughes
haha which you know may be a cautionary
tale I mean it's sort of an interesting
fella definitely want to make sure I
don't go my fingernails too long and
start peeing in jars you beat me to the
line about to say why how choose what is
it about him that you found interesting
I've just been meaning to read a book
about him for ages and I haven't and so
I'm broadly aware of his sort of the
things he's done and I saw the movie The
Aviator and you know and a few a few
other things I like biographies in
general biographies I think I really you
know really interesting reader done for
them well I think you learned a lot
depending upon you know whose life
you're reading about the lots of lessons
in there I read Isaacson's biography of
jobs which I thought was quite
interesting and I actually really liked
I am his biography of mentioned Franklin
who I would say is certainly one of my
heroes he seemed like a really great guy
and you actually managed incorporate any
of this into your own strategy your own
way of doing business your own ethos and
philosophy well I think in the case of
Franklin he did what needed to be done
at the time it needed to be done so no
he was in different fields and and he
sort of thought about okay what's the
important thing used to accomplish right
now and then worked on that
I'm going to show you how to triple your
reading speed in about 20 minutes this
was initially something I learned how to
do I'd say late high school early
college in my neuroscience days and it
turns out most people have never been
taught how to read properly and you
think of reading in a straight line line
by line in fact your eye jumps around to
fixation points and each of those
fixation points is usually a quarter to
a half a second and that if you if you
close one eye and cover the lid with a
finger and then try to trace a straight
line across a wall so the other eye
you'll feel these very distinct jumps
these saccadic movements so the fewer of
those jumps you have and the shorter the
fixation points the faster you read also
if you look at my finger focus on my
finger can you see this hand yeah of
course you can what about this guy I can
focus on it yeah you can and when you're
reading you're usually eating up I would
say a good twenty percent of your
peripheral vision on margins okay we can
take advantage of that so it's very very
straightforward to double triple your
reading speed in very short order what I
want you to do is get a before word per
minute rate and all you have to do to do
that is grab a book could be any book
all you're going to do is look at full
text pages like these and we'd say ten
lines count up the total number of words
divide by ten that's your average number
of words per line okay then all you need
to do is look at say four or five pages
add up the number of lines per page
usually it's between thirty and forty
lines per page and using these two
numbers you can figure out the average
number of words per page okay now once
you've done that you can then read for a
minute just normally as you would not
rushing and use a stop watch boom
calculate things that is your word per
minute starting with all right our goal
is to improve what gets measured gets
managed so now you have your wpm word
per minute rate as a starting next what
we're going to do is we're gonna do the
same thing and the only difference is
we're going to use a pacer alright so
you're going to underline the lines as
go so you're going to try that and that
will probably increase your reading
speed by fifty to one-hundred percent
after we do that what we're going to do
is play with peripheral vision so let's
take some sample sentences this is once
upon a time I had an eight pack those
were happy days then Christmas came
along oh all right so look at these
sentences now most people if you're
using a pacer would start at once right
it's going to be hard for me to do
something it backwards it started once
and then move all the way across to the
end and then boom come back all the way
to the return here you don't have to do
that you don't have to do that because
you have this peripheral vision we're
talking about so what are we going to do
we're actually going to start actually
going to start two or three words in
your fixation point your pencil tip or
your pen tip will be at upon and then
we'll end on had and then you'll return
to those and then end on days and then
start again on can see how that works
all right so you're doing the same
zig-zag pattern you're just compressing
it from the sides in and one way that
you can do that you can certainly just
use the Pacer and you can eyeball it
since be or you can take a ruler or a
postcard and do this right so go down
the margins cutting in one or two words
and if you want to be conservative just
start cutting in one word so once upon
write you're going to start on a pile
and can go straight down and then once
you get comfortable with that then you
can you can move it in a little bit more
a little bit more and just using these
two techniques test out your word for a
minute reading rate again and then the
last test I would say is practice
reading at twice your target speed so
practice beyond your comprehension level
at nine hundred points for a minute for
two or three minutes then go back and
read for comprehension and use the Pacer
indent from the sides and you will find
that that pushes you even further here's
what happens so I go through the book
and as I'm reading I'm looking for the
golden nuggets of information so chances
are you've probably read some great
books in the past but if I told you what
what did you specifically get out of the
book you couldn't tell me you know you
forget about it
and
so I want to make sure whenever I read a
great book I don't forget the most
important parts in it now some people
you know highlight the you know they'll
highlight it and that's what I used to
do I used to just highlight the book but
how many times you actually go back and
you know reread your highlights it's not
very often and so here's the strategy
that I follow when I'm reading I've got
the highlighter handy and so yes I do
highlight but then if I want to commit
it to memory see if you highlight it you
might remember it a little bit more but
when you rewrite that point it sinks
into your mind quite a bit more and so
actually take that and I rewrite it into
my journal here so and then the act of
writing it obviously causes me to be
able to internalize up more and remember
it more and so I'm taking the most
powerful part of the book and I'm
putting it in these journals now then
once I've finished the book I reread the
I reread my notes on that and then I
highlight the most important notes that
I wrote and so you can see here just
from this book I'll you know I mean it
goes on and on and on but I've got my
highlights in here now this is one of
the reasons why for me it's very easy to
do trainings it's very easy for me to do
blog post and you know train on
different things that can add value to
people's lives so my reading habits in
terms of how I learn how I try to gulp
sometimes I'll read a book summary
sometimes I'll read the whole book from
front to back I'm reading the Johnny
Carson book it really resonates with me
and and I'm learning a lot so I'm
reading it pretty much word-for-word I
tend to speed read a little bit but not
too much there's other books that I read
one chapter and I'm like this is enough
you know sometimes people go oh I you're
not really reading a book a day yeah
well I am actually because if I skeets
speed read one book I'll read four or
five in a day so in terms of volume
others all these people out there that
are crazy
they spend their whole time trying to
find loopholes and end little
inconsistencies and what people say so
there's no inconsistency with what I say
in the sense of reading because I really
do read that much but it's not always in
the
methodology in the same modality of
reading so my recommendation to you is
to try shake it up a little bit and one
of the modalities I want to introduce in
this video is you don't need to have 20
or 30 books I'm not actually going to do
this with 20 or 30 I'll probably pick a
random row of books they're all
different kind of subjects let's see
this one is called the creator code the
attacker's advantage John F Kennedy Carl
Sagan's Cosmos the opposite of small and
barefoot to billionaire autobiography so
I might take that row of five or six
books and I'll just pick and choose
today like today's my mode is like
gulping mode so I'm gonna read and what
happens is and this is what Bill Gates
does ok Bill Gates he takes a book
vacation and he brings huge stacks of
books that he hasn't had time to read
and he tries to get through them all and
he says that's his most creative time
because what happens is the idea starts
the ideas start mixing matching bumping
into each other and I think it's James
Altucher or somebody wrote you know it's
like ideas having babies right two
people bump together they get married
whatever they have a kid now there's
three so sometimes with these books you
get an exponential effect one book gives
you a linear response uh you know the
one book one increase in knowledge one
unit or knowledge but you put two or
three books and you don't just have two
or three you have ten that's synergy so
try that sometime so if you're a lot of
time to read for the day is fifteen
minutes just skim through three books
for 15 minutes remember if that bothers
you tomorrow you can go back to the old
way of reading one book at a time always
be mixing and matching humans do a lot
better with recipes of variety I think a
lot of people and your students that are
getting ready to go back to school had
the experience of I can't learn all this
this too much here what am I looking for
have you ever had that experience yes
yes what if I told you there's only five
things you need to know go for it and if
you've learned just those five things
you'll get an A in anything you do
whether it's at work or school alright
give a toy
to the five things is the words the
vocabulary 80% of learning a new subject
is learning the vocabulary so what words
are you looking for
they're bolded they're italic they're
underlying there in strange fonts
they're in color they might be in a
table something is different the writer
wanted you to notice these words don't
look the same as well as a SS is one of
these things is not like the others but
they did it on purpose to draw your
attention so the words are the first
thing the second thing our names who's
in your book and what did they do the
third thing is any number date
statistical formula what is it how do
you use it what does it mean the fourth
thing this is very important in most
nonfiction books there are headings and
subheadings that you're basically like
thematic folders they keep the
information that's related to itself in
a container and what you're looking for
what are the five most important ideas
contained in every section and
subsection and the last thing you're
looking for are the questions and the
answers you ever get to the end of a
chapter and there are a bunch of
questions you're like I didn't really
look at that very much I didn't realize
it was important what if you had read
the questions first and knew what was
important mmm then when you saw it it
say this is important they asked
questions about this would that make a
big difference in your understanding Wow
John Brooks is an unbelievable business
writer he's probably my favorite and
it's too bad so many people haven't had
a chance to care about him and the great
work he did he loved stories with vivid
characters venal bumbling brilliant you
name it he loved them he was a novelist
at heart and he found a lot of good
stories in wall street a Warren Buffett
gave me a copy of business adventures
feeling like with our dialogue about
trying to understand the world the
business that I'd enjoyed as much as he
had and in fact it was phenomenal oh I I
do even like it I mean that was written
for him it was written for me too if
you're gonna run a company you should
read the impacted philosophers and when
you learn how really probably pretty
decent people start behaving in bad ways
it's that's fascinating he talks about
these people in GE who would wink when
they would actually say what the
rulebook said to do now remember you
cannot talk to our competitors about
this when you know which is essentially
saying go talk to them but he makes it
come alive in a particular way he makes
it come alive is common because he
understands that most of the time if you
look closely enough the motives of the
people involved are as short-sighted and
self-serving the motives and that's
material economy Ford Motor Company was
super successful they introduced a car
called the Edsel and they spent more
money on picking the name and planning
the futures than it ever been spent on
any new American product and yet it was
an abysmal failure Ford counted on
selling at least 200,000 ensel's the
first year there may be an Aborigine
somewhere in a remote rainforest who
hasn't yet heard that things failed to
turn out that way I just love that line
and yet in a way the Edsel wasn't so bad
he'd embodied much of the spirit of its
time or at least at the time when it was
designed
early in 1955 it was clumsy powerful
dowdy gauche well-meaning a de Kooning
woman I think you can read this book
today and learn a lot all the work of
Michael Lewis comes directly from works
I mean he really was the Michael Lewis
of his day the rules of running a great
business value creation are unchanged
and Brooks took some very dramatic
examples that are particularly fun and
interesting and instructive I read a
book recently myself Goodin that really
is it's called linchpin and I'm a big
fan of staffs he's a friend of mine he's
just he's a he's very poetic and
brilliant and it takes complex things
that makes them very simple but writes
them in a very inspiring way so I chose
book right now but these days I meet on
my iPads oh I'd really go pick up his
book I think it's really tiny can read
it really quick and I think it give you
some really nice insights and then one
of the book I just like to recommend to
you I think features have a little bit
of time here it's called the happiness
hypothesis by Jonathan hate and probably
miss pouncing his name I hope I'm not
but it's a book I read when it first
came out several years ago but it's one
of the best books I've read to show you
the scientific understanding of how you
really experience a life of fulfillment
because as things get more difficult the
old style of being happy that so many
people used up you know let me just get
what I want we all know that doesn't
work but it becomes more obvious when
the economy contracts and I just one of
my missions is to make sure people are
really truly fulfilled in their lives on
that they I believe that happens by
contribution by relationships by making
a difference by having your life have
meaning beyond yourself and yes you can
get your toys and I've had the privilege
of doing that but it never fills anybody
up this book let me tell you that in a
few words or some silly little quote I
think it'll give you some stuff that's
real food for thought will move you and
it will kind of give you a little
pathway to see what are the real ways to
have lasting happiness and fulfillment
you know one of my really important
colleagues on my team one of my managers
Karen BZ
she suggested I read the book The
Alchemist and it changed my whole life
because I realized all of the people who
had conspired to get me to this place oh
I love the alchemist man that book is it
will change your life it's the one who
know what it why because it absolutely
shows you that if you have the desire
the universe will rise up to meet you
exactly where you are
yes yeah oh yes yeah yes you have to be
unafraid to dream right and then you
have to be even more brave and gallant
about blueprinting what you've envisage
yes you got to be brave about that so
you read The Alchemist and then it was
like clear to me I was like wow so maybe
at some point in your life you've
dreamed about becoming a millionaire
well this book takes it to the next
level how to become a billionaire which
I'm rich this is one of the best books
I've ever read on how to make money and
this guy went out and he surveyed and
studied all the top billionaires he
ended up coming up with around ten
principles that you have to follow to
become extra wealth let me tell you
about the three top self-development
books that have had such a great impact
on me the first one which I stumbled
across many many years ago was called
Think and Grow Rich by Napoleon Hill now
Napoleon Hill was a journalist and a
writer and he was called in to visit
with Andrew Carnegie one of the richest
most successful business magnets in the
world at that time and then Carnegie
said I want you to help me to develop a
philosophy of success I will open the
doors to the 500 richest people in
America so that you can interview them
as many times as you need to then take
all the best information from these 500
people and put it into a series of books
to help other young people to be
successful much faster but it won't pay
you a penny what do you say and the
probe in Hill had thought this man was
going to hire him and Payman enormous
amount of money to do this writing he
was shocked and he
that there he tells about it later he
sat there and he thought and he thought
that he finally said okay I'll do it and
then Andrew Carnegie pulled his watch
out from under the desk and he said you
had 60 seconds to give me an answer
you made your answer in 46 seconds he
then went on to open the door to every
wealthy person in America people who had
started from nothing and become
extraordinarily rich and what Napoleon
Hill did is he took over the years and
he found that there were 17 principals
that wealthy people had qualities and
behaviors he found that no one started
off with these qualities and behaviors
and he found that they were all learn
about now my second one is would be my
own book maximum achievement napoleon
hill's book was written in the 20s and
30s my maximum achievement was written
for the 21st century
and it shows you how to completely
change the way you think how to set
goals in every area of your life how to
dramatically take control of your life
in every area and eliminate the negative
emotions that hold people back now
another book that I would recommend that
I have always liked is the power of
positive thinking by Norman Vincent
Peale Norman Vincent Peale I knew him
and I worked with them before he died he
was a minister and he came up with some
very very interesting ideas about how
the more positive you think the more
energy you have the more grateful you
are for the things in your life the more
things that you will have to be grateful
for
just like I teach and other people teach
you'll attract into your life people in
circumstances in harmony with your
dominant thoughts thank you so much for
watching
I made this episode of believe life
because Spike Z to 108 asked me to so
this is a topic that you want me to
cover on the next edition of believe
life leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of the points that you heard
in this video resonated the most with
you which you learn the most from you're
going to go take some action on leave it
in the comments I'm really curious to
find out thank you so much for watching
have a great day continue to believe and
I'll see you soon